yeah this is a list of every billionaire
that we can find
in the world where we feel confident
that we can prove somebody
has a fortune worth a billion dollars
each person needs to be
an individual billionaire we've got a
record number this year on our
billionaires list
2755 people the most ever
and that includes 493 newcomers
205 of the newcomers are from china
excluding hong kong and
macau i think it is surprising to see
that
there are more billionaires than ever um
and that the among the richest
in the world that their world has really
grown during a time
where a lot of people may be struggling
and there might be a lot of ups and
downs and uneven recovery
it is quite surprising
as i've mentioned before to see
you know a record number of billionaires
from china
which you know during last year's list
was kind of
in the height of a lockdown the stock
markets there were
faltering um you know factory production
was down
and there were you know a lot of issues
and
and for the country to produce almost as
many billionaires as the us
a year later as bit of a remarkable
recovery
altogether the people on this year's
list are worth 13.1
trillion dollars which is a very hard
number to wrap your head around
and that's up from eight trillion
dollars last year so that is a
huge increase um you know part of it is
that we have more billionaires but part
of it is that the billionaires who are
on there
are worth a lot more one who's worth a
whole lot more
of course is the number two um richest
on the list
was elon musk at certain points in
january was worth more than jeff bezos
um but by the time we used stock prices
from early march
uh musk had fallen below bezos by
about 26 billion dollars he's still
worth 151 billion which is a whole lot
more than the 26 billion he was worth
a year ago jeff bezos is number uh one
richest for the fourth year in a row
worth a hundred and
seventy seven billion dollars basically
that's um the value of his amazon stock
um
he sells stock every once in a while and
he uses it to fund his
um blue origin space company he gave a
quarter of his
amazon stake to his uh ex-wife mckenzie
um when they got divorced um but it
didn't really
keep him from being number one his
ex-wife mackenzie scott
is number 22 on the list worth 53
billion dollars
and that's after she gave away nearly
six billion dollars of her fortune last
year
to 500 different uh groups across the
country
um ranging from historically black
colleges to
local ymcas and wcas and meals on wheels
and all kinds of places like that
we see you know right now the world's
youngest
self-made billionaire austin russell who
founded a company
that produces lidar which allows
self-driving cars kind of
sense and see things around them he
became a billionaire via a stack ipo
out of the age of 25. crypto obviously
has gone up
by a lot uh bitcoin and other coins you
know we see the win kavas
twins which people probably know from
facebook becoming billionaires
and i think the last trend is that we
are also seeing a lot of healthcare
related billionaires we track at least
billionaires who have become a new
billionaire this year because of
fortunes
related to covid so a lot of these are
you know
vaccine makers test makers
hospital chains protective gear makers
so this is kanye's first time being on
the official
billionaires list you know mainly his
fortune comes from
this lucrative deal that he has to
design uh these yeezy
shoes for adidas um which are super
popular sell for hundreds of dollars
he's also struck a deal to design
clothes for
gaap um those clothes have not
uh begun to sell yet so forbes isn't
really giving
that gap partnership any value yet but
we
we've got um kanye's net worth at 1.8
billion dollars
and then the other newcomer who's gonna
make headlines i think for for being on
the list for the first time
is uh kanye west's ex ex-wife or soon to
be ex-wife kim
kardashian west she's
made a lot of money from makeup from kkw
beauty which she sold a stake in that to
cody a publicly traded
cosmetics company um and she also has a
lingerie undergarment company called
skims
which um has really taken off and uh
between those two things she
she crosses the billion dollar mark for
the first time we also know that we're
missing billionaires
around the world you know that that it
some managed to slip through the cracks
it's there's a little bit of cognitive
dissonance that goes on when you do this
list because at a time when we've all
been
on lockdown and people are you know
there's lines for
food banks and you see you know the the
negative effects of the pandemic
and then on the flip side to see the
huge increase
in the number of billionaires it
definitely underlines
this trend that i think we've seen in
our country where
more of the gains of the wealth have
gone to the
very richest in our society